drinks that just drinks or dinner and  drinks if it's just drinks I got to eat  before so I don't get too drunk but if  it's dinner then I can't eat before or  she'll be the only one eating and  that'll be brew  maybe I bring a bag of trail mix and eat  it in the bathroom you could just ask  her you know is this dinner but that is  does that make it a date hey hey when  someone says let's get drinks does that  mean just drinks or dinner and drinks  it's dawn my whole game what time of the  drinks 8:30 ish 8:30 it's too late to be  dinner it's gotta just be drinks you're  a hunter sure just drink or sure it's  gotta be all right yes some with drinks  okay drinks by rinks only drinks drinks  drinks oh well hey thirty could just be  dinner if she's European